I'm very privileged in a whole lot of
ways and then in other ways I'm very not
[Music]
I would define privilege as something
that gives any particular person an
advantage over the mass population I
still don't know what I'm going to say
some people may have things easier than
others and by easy I don't mean like you
still don't go through really hard
things in your life but maybe you have a
little bit more help my hands are like
sweating I would define privilege as a
quality that gives a person an advantage
over other people and that quality could
be related to your race or gender
identity your family upbringing I would
define privilege based off of income and
I feel like a lot of the time we base it
off of race but they're directly
correlated privilege to me is kind of
like an asset or advantage that people
have based off their upbringing whether
it's race where they live who their
friends are trying to define privilege I
realized put in the spot is a lot more
difficult than I thought it would be it
really made me think how there are a lot
of different aspects to this
conversation
[Music]
[Music]
it's a word in the dictionary but it
means so much more than what it's what
the definition is and I feel like the
real definition encompasses so much more
than what you can write on paper when I
saw everybody that was gonna be in the
lineup I kind of thought I was gonna be
more toy as a front but to see what
actually happened it just it kind of
opens your eyes to different people's
experiences and different people's lives
honestly I wasn't surprised by where I
ended up and it's literally just because
how I've grown up question
what about like teachers like college
teachers every one of my families is
educated most of them are Ivy League
educated so for me it's I've always felt
a little guilty about the privilege that
I have when I look at other black
Americans in the country
[Music]
I'm comfortable to say that I have a
little bit of privilege because of my
upbringing but I don't think I didn't
expect myself to make it that far I'm
very blessed and I've been able to
surpass a lot of expectations of what a
privileged person in America looks like
I didn't necessarily expect to be the
furthest behind in the lineup but I like
to change my perspective on it because I
grew up low-income and I still had like
a lot more privileges than a lot of
people who I know I just liked seeing
that there was one on each line it was
kind of cool that we got to each kind of
represent different lines and I also
just have an appreciation for all of us
in all of our journeys like we all have
different stories and backgrounds and is
really cool to kind of see that we you
don't know what a person's lived
experiences ever
you
they do it too high despite me being
right in the front I didn't think I was
gonna land that I don't know if they had
to do with my privilege or my lack of
athletic ability I was honestly in the
best position on the line like yeah leah
was one step ahead but she's also to the
right of me I'm directly in front of
this thing I just happen to suck at this
game however if I was good at the game
it would have been a cinch
I don't like yard games the experience
of the game was a really cool
metaphorical representation of the
imbalances
I guess I'm destroying the challenges oh
I need I need a better art I'm a
competitive person but knowing that I
was three rows back compared to some
other people or just different roles
compared to other people didn't really
bother me it just seemed like I just had
it a different obstacle that is like
life though I just hope I didn't land on
that that was fire making the shot like
I guess was like proving to myself that
I could do it seeing like Asia is over
here
like that's crazy that I'm literally
standing right in front of it she did it
and that was that was really awesome to
see so many people have gone through
different trials tribulations that you
don't know so don't judge oh the
experience of the game was interesting
it was a way to kind of conceptualize a
subject that's hard for us to talk about
honestly I was a little embarrassed I
try not I don't like talking about money
or privilege or class or race or
anything like that but I do think that
this is a conversation that needs to be
had the biggest thing that we can do is
like recognize where we are in terms of
our own personal privilege
and try and build up people who are less
privileged than we are
[Music]
[Music]
you